my guests this week are Faisal Syed Ali
Matar and Melissa Chen they work
together at the global secular humanist
movement a platform committed to the use
of critical reason factual evidence and
scientific methods of inquiry rather
than faith and mysticism in seeking
solutions to human problems and answers
to important human questions
that was a serious intro you guys write
a nice boilerplate there I gotta tell
you well I tried my best you gave me all
those are all the buzzwords that we talk
about all the time right exactly yeah
and the word committed is the most
important one committed yeah
committed so that these principles
because it's very hard to be consistent
these days it is hard to be especially
as you know with some of the folks we
concern our allies but they they have
their mind on Christianity but on other
stuff they change their mind so yeah the
word committed here is I think is the
most important one right so you're
itching to get right into it you get
into hours I flew all the way from New
York yeah yeah all right so we're going
to talk about our friend off course of
course
Faisal you've been on the show before I
have yeah thank you for inviting me
again
yeah my pleasure so you guys work
together and I want to do a little bit
just on your history's first so since
we've had Faisal here let's start with
you Melissa so you are originally from
Singapore yes I moved here in 2004 for
college worked and and then you don't
went to grad school and continued
working I loved it and I you know I got
sold the American Dream and and the
American ideals I think you know in part
it's the same thing that drew both of us
here you know we couldn't have more
different backgrounds phase all grew up
under a dictatorship in Baghdad and he
has only known war and strife his whole
life but I've had a interesting parallel
childhood in Singapore where it's a
benevolent dictatorship so you know he
grew under those circumstances but it
was safe and and and very prosperous you
know city and life there is stable yeah
so I think the people at least in
America I'm trying to expand some
some worldly knowledge on people but I
feel like people don't really know
anything about Singapore so when you say
a benevolent dictatorship what does that
even mean well it's been a single-party
state since 1965 one government has one
party has ruled the country since since
that time ever since it's gained
independence and and they are you know
economic freedoms are extremely well
developed in Singapore I think Heritage
Foundation listed us two out of 180 on
their economic Freedom Index right but
if you look at political freedom you
know our freedom of expression freedom
of the press it's virtually non-existent
right so basically there's freedom to
sort of pursue the work that you want
but not necessarily you say the things
that you want it is a neoliberal
contradiction in that regard because
it's extremely fiscally austere low
taxes free trade deregulation it's all
the buzzwords that you know the
right-wing economists you know love
right but on the other hand you know I
think it's it's sort of throwing a
wrench into Milton Friedman's
capitalism of freedom this theory about
he said that economic freedom was a
necessary precondition to political
freedom and civil freedoms and that's
not really happening right so that's
really interesting so Singapore sort of
got half of it right yes the economic
part but not not the social part in the
political part right now of course you
come from both of them along in my
country we got one for two and you got
over to a little bit has to do with some
of the things that we did here in
America so for the people that don't
know you're sorry give me like a two
minute recap of growing up in Iraq and
catches up on well I mean I was born in
Iraq and I was born in Babylon and
raised in Baghdad my first years was
under Saddam Hussein dictatorship and
then afterwards the US invasion of Iraq
happened and continuous civil war I mean
my spark for activism was kind of a mix
of course after the Earth's intervention
there like we had the first rocky
elections
and I saw the rise of sectarian politics
and I'm since I was a young boy back
then I was advocating for secular values
and just to prevent the rise of
terrorist groups like what we have right
now because I was afraid that if we want
a group takes over the other and that
did not obviously go I left so within
like the Civil War was rising I lost
members of my family was my brother lost
my cousin and I was also I lost some
friends and I had to leave Iraq in 2009
and actually a year afterwards I started
like the pages of a second humorous
movement that eventually came one of the
largest in the world
and I left Iraq I went to country close
to Singapore Malaysia and I applied for
asylum me through the NHC our we had
Nations Committee for Refugees and I get
accepted to come to America yeah
so that's why I wanted to have you both
on together because I think it's really
interesting people that come from
different places and I say on the show
all the time the ideas we talked about
here transcend borders and they train
Missa tee and nationality and all of
those things so when you were there and
when you were growing up there was did
you have a political awakening while you
were there did you realise that you
couldn't say some of the things that you
want to say and that kind of stuff
absolutely so Singapore late you don't
when you first entry when somebody's
learns that I am from this country they
will say one or two things um the first
one is I heard chewing gum is banned
I heard you can't bring bubble gum until
is that true yes it is true every
chewing gum well it used to be that
they've relaxed it a little so so you
can't purchase it now you can't purchase
chewing gum there and it's for very kind
of silly reason you're working possibly
back in the 1980s you know Singapore was
developing economically right but but
you can develop really fast economically
but the the people's mindsets and
civility and and tragedy of the Commons
sort of mindset has had not developed so
they would litter you know you stick
your chewing gum on the doors of the
trains and then they get stuck and so
the government was like we're
gonna spend tax dollars cleaning this up
so you can't handle the chewing gum
we're gonna take it away wow so that
talk about an authority really at a very
micro level like how authoritarian the
government yeah and that's that's a good
example the second one is you know if
one of the sort of the best gifts you
you can get in Singapore further like a
tourist to bring home that that people
usually get is a t-shirt that says
Singapore is a science city and on it
there all the different fines that you
can get like you cannot eat on the on
the public you know the public trains
roads and it's just a country with very
strong rule of law and all sorts of all
sorts of rules that you can't do this
and you can't do that and everything
other the guise of maintaining social
harmony yeah now I assume it's some
level that probably works right at some
level the the social harmony we have not
had you know radicalization of our sunni
muslim population not as much as any
other country actually i would say yeah
and it's been largely you know you've
had you have Christians Hindus Buddhists
Muslims living very harmoniously
together we've not had any incidents so
there is something to be said about
about the methods of top-down
institutionalization of social harmony
the problem is that manifests itself in
sedition laws mm-hmm blasphemy laws and
as recently as last year it was used to
throw a seventeen-year-old blogger into
jail mm-hmm for wounding the feelings of
religious people all he did was say some
stuff about Jesus Christ and to point at
least 20 grown-up adults in Singapore
felt offended enough to file a police
report and they threw a 17 year-old and
to jail right so we've talked a little
bit about what they've done to bloggers
in Bangladesh and Singapore and you've
connected me with a Bangladeshi blogger
who I'm gonna have on soon now these are
the people that we need to be caring
about more right because these are the
people that you guys could have been had
not less yeah yeah I mean there I mean
everyone knows like whatever one of
these one of these folks get killed or
like what happened in Bangladesh all
right but I was already a good job we
know that these guys are the solution we
know that they stand for the same values
that we stand for and we know that they
are the best counter they create the
best counter narrative to extremists
Alec right Badawi like he's the Sam
Harris of Saudi Arabia yes he's
intellectual who has advocated for great
values that in a country that is as
Extreme as Saudi Arabia they would have
changed the world
Saudi Arabia that is one of the main
exporter of Mohave ideology that killed
the Bangala bloggers that that created
the Taliban which country that has the
nuclear weapons so yeah I mean we have
to our best resource that we should
always continue to help them as much as
we can and whenever we can yeah so when
you were there and you saw this sort of
authoritarianism
when did you realize all right if I'm
gonna express what's in me I may have to
leave I just I realized that in high
school in in in Singapore many many of
the best schools like those at the top
you know in academia they were religious
schools you know just it's just like a
sort of a distinction of the colonial
era when like the British came it was a
British colony and and you had all the
missionaries from France from from from
Europe they came to set up schools to
educate the locals and and so this
became associated with academics like
high academic standards so I ended up
going to you know Methodist schools
which were associated with very high
academic standards right did you grow up
Methodist yes and I did and I did so so
the religious the religious schools were
are quite a force to reckon with in
Singapore mm-hmm and in producing
graduates and I guess I realized that I
mean this is a country that that is very
self enforcing in terms of political
correctness if you can't you know
there's all sorts of rules and and and
you the reason people don't don't do
something or don't litter is the
cuz there's there's a fine waiting to
happen
yeah so so the motivation to to do
something or to not do something is
completely extrinsic so we're all self
policing each other and I sort of you
know bought into the the sort of ideal
of the United States the First Amendment
you know the freedom of expression of
freedom of speech because I was always
that rebellious you know skeptic in my
circle in my religious circle and and
school which is pretty much overlapped
at that point and that's when I realized
I I need to get out yeah really need to
get out if I if I need it if I want it
to broaden my mind and fulfill that yeah
I'm curious when you hear the phrase
self policing in a place like Singapore
and there are self policing because of
fines and sort of this authoritarian
thing so one of the things I've been
saying on the show all the time is that
we are now self policing ourselves in
America so it's not coming you know we
always used to fear the idea that the
the government is what's gonna come in
and take away our fries yeah but now
it's we're doing it to ourselves and
what's happening in academia which I
want to talk to you guys in a little bit
but when you hear that does that make
you crazy knowing from where you came
exactly I mean it's 1984 but people lies
yeah I mean to be honest I when I before
I came to United States I had like a
very good image of what like when I came
to America the people especially the
people who believed in same values as I
am the secular liberals of the of the
West would just give and did they at
first because the movement has changed
right something on the left has changed
over the last couple years so when you
moved here I'm guessing maybe it was a
little more welcoming I mean it was I
mean it was welcoming but I I thought it
would be more welcoming I didn't know
that there was this a huge splits the
fact that if I can if anybody can be
advocating for same-sex marriage in a
western country it's totally okay but
the moment you talk about it in a auslan
country it becomes yeah you're wrong
okay yeah yeah
I didn't know about these dynamics that
when you talk about the the same values
that the American liberals that have
kept for when you move it to an
Universal or another countries you would
immediately be called a racist and so
when I got into that I start getting
attacked left or right like of what I'm
saying is that I support same-sex
marriage and they're like oh well that
is a form of colonialism are you [ __ ]
kidding me because yeah you are saying
the same thing for like the United
States and I just said that I believe
that gays are humans even in Iraq like I
think they're humans they they breathe
and they have the same DNA of a human
being so are you my big really out-there
stuff so like I don't really think of
myself as a radical person like I I
think that I'm advocating as but the
moment you just shifted to a different
culture coracoid because what I found
very difficult here is that because
we're minorities i I come from the
majority even though I'm an atheist I'm
a minority all the time right but what
comes the color of my skin I'm the
majority so here in America there is
this concept of the authentic voice when
it comes to minorities is that there are
these stereotypes whether it's from the
right on the left like if you are from
this specific race these the issues that
you should care about the most in this
specific order yeah like if you are a
Mexican you should care about
immigration and so on and if you if you
are Arab they expect this image about
okay he's an he's a young Arab man so he
must hate the West he must be very angry
against the United States about what
Bush did to the Iraq and they must hate
capitalism and he must all this stuff so
if you don't fit into that narrative
you're immediately gonna be like
attacked as some sort of like Uncle Tom
or trader which is itself racist without
them noticing it right that's what I
keep saying they're actually using real
racism exactly they're not judging you
by what's in your mind they're judging
you by what they like wrong as a grave
right now because it's like the so
that's actually one of the most
difficult two things I found over here
is that how come he don't subscribe to
my already my notions of who you should
be
like I'm like I'm individual as you are
and and and now like we can see it in
the US elections in which I've seen many
people on both sides I would say
especially I would say on the far left
who are like how can you as a as a black
know support Bernie
okay I'm thing like that well black
people have they have they have agency
and they may rush rationally think of
supporting one person of the other like
you can disagree with them and that's
completely fine but to say like why is
he as a black person you don't say that
about the white person let's say like
maybe air support Trump but right and
coming again from white people exactly
the left critical race Theory from like
white guilt Universal Aleph or Nia they
are suddenly now experts of race
relations and what the dynamics of their
beliefs are right and they just like
project themselves as being their
intellectuals so that's that's really
interesting and and because we talk so
much about the Middle East and we talk
about extremism and Islam or whatever I
see a very specific reason why you get
something like that
I'm curious having left Singapore having
you know believing in secular values and
atheism and all that do you find some of
that that soft bigotry of low
expectations and that we talk about no I
don't
in fact I'm probably a beneficiary of
high expectations right I mean so when
he left that joke that Chris Rock made
at the Oscars with the little kids
little accountants and and you know for
some reason the Asian community was
really up in arms about that stereotype
yeah even though it's a positive
stereotype so what did you feel when you
heard that that okay so I did get into
some online fights about this because
again as Faysal says because of your
race you know like seemingly Asian
person you should be finding this thing
offensive right
you should have laugh at it you should
you know assail and rally against and
sort of deny stereotypes forgetting that
this is in the context of humor and and
the same thing with what they're Sacha
Baron Cohen said about the little mini
ones like that really blue like even
Jeremy Lin the basketballs yeah
into that yeah and I think it's just you
know I was asking people rhetorically
like what what happens to comedy if if
you just take all stereotypes out of it
you have to be angry at South Park you
have to be angry at I don't know
everybody yeah I mean this whole season
do you guys watch South Park this easy I
mean this whole season I think it might
have been the best season ever literally
the entire season was dedicated me watch
it yeah well there you go it was
dedicated to fighting these exact ideas
right exactly
and and to thinking about taking offense
is you know I always ask people like who
creates the offense the offense the the
person who offended or the person who
feels the offense yeah who's the one
that actually created it because it does
it happen in a vacuum right so there's a
particularly interesting notion with
what you're saying because the
stereotype so when Chris Rock brought
out yeah one of them was actually had a
Jewish name angry so just for people who
didn't see it so they brought out three
Asian kids one of them had a Jewish name
and they were supposed to all be like
accountant
Price Waterhouse yeah so they were all
supposed to be really bright accountants
Baba but so the stereotype that they're
using is a positive stereo these are
educated kids that are gonna go on very
good at math and they you know excel
academically right so when when people
were upset with you or when you said I'm
okay with the humor in that
yeah the people that were upset what
were what were they saying like did they
feel that that's causing some sort of
backlash yeah they don't like the
perpetuating of the model minority and
they think that that sets up a standard
where now every Asian has to live up to
that yeah I think they're reading too
much into it you know it's it's it's
just a reflection of stereotypes that
have the grain of truth in the case of
Ali G who made that joke about he said
well you know this dis Oscars is all
about diversity but what about them
little yellow guys you know who have the
little dogs yeah and then he paused
everybody laughed
right so everybody who seemed like he
was talking about Asians yeah and
he said oh you know the minions so the
joke was actually on you because you are
the ones who did the stereotyping huh
and and I don't think people they just
reacted to that they were like oh I was
saying you know that Asians have small
small dongs and I was just like well
actually this is the anatomy of humor
and if you don't know Ali G as a
character and and how he's playing off
his humor he's actually saying you're
the one who is there right so just to be
clear he did some really clever there
because he took you one way made you
laugh and then immediately takes you the
other place so you're right it's on you
it's on you you're the one who's
stereotype ya laughed and you thought
that he meant Asian people
[Music]